the united states has a new president
sworn in during a ceremony that was a
mix of familiar tradition
and extraordinary precaution normally
joe biden's oath would have been
witnessed by tens of thousands
but due to the dual threat of the
pandemic and extremist violence
security forces made up the biggest
crowd at the capitol
outgoing president trump broke with
custom and stayed away
joe biden immediately signed a slew of
executive orders to reverse trump's
policies promising to heal
the country's deep partisan divisions
after trump's wrecking ball can joe
biden fix
america that's our topic
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it's a
pleasure to introduce our guests
malta lehming writes for the berlin
daily the tagaspigo
and he formally led the paper's
washington bureau he argues
biden stands for unity and
reconciliation but many other democrats
want trump and his supporters to be
brought to account
it doesn't fit together and it's great
to have matthew carnegie with us
on the program once again he's european
correspondent with the us daily
politico his opinion biden will manage
to repair america's divisions
whether he'll succeed in repairing the
relationship with germany
and europe is a different matter
and great to have with us suda david
wilk she is from the transatlantic think
tank german marshall fund
and she says joebine will install a new
version of global leadership for america
but he will also think about policy in
terms of how it affects the american
middle class
one headline that we're seeing in the
newspapers reads
inauguration triumphed over insurrection
referring to the worries that we could
see a repeat of the extremist
violence that gripped the capitol just
two weeks before the inauguration
let me get a quick reaction from all of
you about what was
uppermost in your minds as you watched
the inauguration matthew well it felt to
me like a
restoration of american norms to be
honest to
see biden there with former presidents
clinton obama and george w bush sitting
behind him
as well as many republicans including
former vice president now
mike pence it felt to me like the entire
ceremony was a important step
towards reconciliation and towards
normalization
of american democratic life sure
i would agree with matthew and um i
think it was also a big contrast the two
speeches
what we heard from president trump um in
2017 about american carnage
versus american healing um what we
this week with president biden and i
think my daughter
captured the moment very well who's 16
you know who has
experienced president trump these past
four years she said it was so refreshing
to hear
president biden's speech yeah a lot of
people have used the words refreshing
and relieved
malta what about the view from uh
from someone who knows washington well
but of course
uh is uh is of german roots i'm afraid i
have to
i have to say relief as well um there is
a deep sense of that because we lived in
the four years of permanent
the feeling of tension uh you never know
what's going to happen
each day and and now the feeling that
that things are coming back to civility
and normalcy and quietness and
and reason um in washington dc
uh yeah it was a sense of relief soda
mentioned
carnage uh which was of course uh the
reference uh to
donald by donald trump in his own
inaugural address and in fact carnage is
what we saw
on january 6 exactly two weeks weeks
before the inauguration
as a mob stormed the capital let's hear
what americans around the country were
saying
in light of those events in the run-up
to the inauguration
about their own concerns for their
country
this is a very very sad time for the
united states right now
and it was incited by one man
and now we have chaos in the united
states
you don't know who to trust these days i
don't know what news network i can trust
i don't know
social media i can trust i don't know
what individuals in government i can
trust
i think it's awful um i am
hopeful that we have a leader that will
focus on
unifying i hope that our politicians
will move past the political divide we
just feel hurt it's heartbreaking right
now
this is a this is a wonderful country
that god has given us it's terrifying
just to see
you know the capital of our country and
you know we stand on values like freedom
and democracy and you see these these
walls and these restrictions
the last four years i have been ashamed
to be american
and finally um although i'm not
perhaps a biden advocate
i am for anybody that's not trump
and i'm so excited to bring in this new
change
matthew your opening statement was uh
perhaps
surprisingly optimistic in regard to
biden's ability to heal
those divisions what makes you so
confident
well i think it's as the last woman that
we heard there said
even people who are not particularly
excited about
biden are happy to see trump gone and i
think
that speaks for a large majority
of the population i think in a lot of
the
reporting about the election there's the
sense that the country is still very
divided
and you know that biden only won by a
small margin he actually won by a pretty
convincing margin
he won by seven million votes which is
you know not
not a small number of votes by by any
number
by any measure and you know i think that
if you look at the
polling of the last week in particular
looking at the entire population of the
united states
it's clear that a majority of the
americans are optimistic about biden
they want him to succeed they want the
country to move forward
and i think they just want an end of the
chaos that we've seen
over the past four years at the same
time suda there are polls
taken less than a week before the
inauguration that show
that many many republicans still do
believe
that the election was stolen from
president trump and conservative groups
were very quick to brand the new
president immediately after
the inauguration as far left so how
optimistic are you
that he can truly repair the divide well
i think joe biden is really the right
candidate
for america's division he is a moderate
by
you know all standards and i think he
will want to
govern from the middle he will want to
reach across the aisle and work with
republicans
and it may be that right now the
majority of republican voters and
two-thirds of the republican
caucus are saying that the election was
not legitimate but i do think that there
are
pragmatic republican members that see
that
this um you know illusion or this lie
could really break the republican party
and for the
um you know responsible leaders in the
republican party because i do think
there are still republican
leaders that are responsible it's in
their interest
to um you know sort of get rid of this
bad blood in the republican party and
move forward
one quick point on that i think that
also gets overlooked too often
is that since trump became president the
republicans lost control of the house of
representatives
they announced in the midterms two years
ago they have now lost control of the
senate and they have lost the presidency
so even though he has this very devoted
following
it has become clear that you cannot have
a majority
in the united states on a federal level
with a candidate like
trump because he just loses too many
people in the middle and
and they drift to to the dead i want to
come back to the direction of the
republicans in just a moment but let's
stay
a little bit longer with uh with the new
president and um malta you were in
washington
from 2000 to 2005 if
i'm correct uh joe biden
was a senator for i believe over 35
years and he is known to have a lot of
experience working across the aisle
working with politicians of the other
party even on a friendly
basis with mitch mcconnell the majority
speaker who in fact during the trump
administration and prior to that has
done
everything possible to democrat
denigrate
democrats um biden
these skills that he has they were from
a very different time
in america do you really think they are
still
capable of creating the same kind of
bipartisan
cooperation as in that
past era that's a very good question i
mean
he doesn't actually need the bipartisan
uh
collaboration because as as matthew just
said
the white house the senate and the house
of representatives is all in
the hands of democrats so he has a lot
of leverage
he personally has a biography that that
gives him
some credit personal losses she has
he had in his own family it's very hard
to
to consider him as a partisan politician
what what i think it might be a problem
is
see you had 74 million people voting for
trump
and this is they knew everything it was
everything said about his lies about his
tweets about everything that he did
in in knowledge about that 74 people all
of them have different motives but can
there be something like
reconciliation without any kind of
remorse
that is i think the crucial question do
74 people
feel kind of some kind of oh i'm sorry i
i voted for him and
i supported him four years uh why did
they
well i think a lot of people do regret
it after the six of us
starts with the second lowest approval
rating since uh
since george bush the elder um
it was just uh that george bush junior
started with a lower approval rating
according to pew so so let's come back
to that
in just a moment but i'd like to first
take
a listen to how the newly inaugurated
president himself
is promising to heal the political
divide and what he's had to say
about its causes let's start afresh
all of us let's begin to listen to one
another again
hear one another see one another
show respect to one another there is
truth
and there are lies lies told
for power and for profit
and each of us has a duty and a
responsibility
as citizens as americans and especially
as leaders
leaders who have pledged to honor our
constitution
and protect our nation to defend the
truth
and defeat the lies
matthew that was as close as president
biden got
to mentioning his predecessor's
culpability in his
inaugural remarks and some apparent some
republicans apparently were relieved by
the subtlety
are you seeing signs that the party is
ready to break
with trumpism and trumpism's
instrumentalization that was just
mentioned of hate and lies
i think there are clear signs of that
clearly not everybody is going to do it
but
in the past week we've also seen mitch
mcconnell who you mentioned who's now
the
minority leader in the senate uh
make very clear in that in his view
trump was responsible for the
insurrection on the the 6th of january
mcconnell is somebody who's
stood behind trump throughout the last
four years and it
has now broken with him and the big
question will be when the impeachment
trial of trump begins in the coming
weeks
if mcconnell and others vote to impeach
trump
you need 17 senators in the uh
group of 100 to come over to the
democratic side
there and that will be you know the the
biggest indication
that we'll have but i just make one more
point on that that i think is also often
not really understood is that in the
house of representatives which is a
larger body
you you have uh republicans who are much
more extreme in their views because they
have to appeal to a much
smaller segment of of the populace and
the the senators
represent entire states so they tend to
be much more moderate and i think again
as
i was saying before for these
republicans who want to appeal to a
broader
who need to appeal to a broader slice of
the american public if they want to
remain in power over the long term
they're going to need to uh leave
trumpism
behind and pursue a more inclusive
uh politics the president mentioned
in his uh in his remarks that we just
heard
uh lying for profit and
of course interesting is the fact that a
number of big donors seem to now be
turning away from those politicians who
uh who were most egregious about lying
and supporting
trump what do you think suda could a
second impeachment help discredit
trump in a way that will promote healing
and reconciliation
or could it in fact widen the divisions
so i mean an impeachment process is by
virtue
always bitter and it's usually a
partisan affair but the fact that the
house
impeached president trump with 10
republicans
is quite remarkable and i think january
6 was a
watershed moment the storming of the
capital really was a wake-up call for a
lot of republicans and
mitch mcconnell said you know he told
his caucus
vote your conscience so he's opened the
door to
rep for republicans to find a way to
leave trump-ism behind and the question
is will the
senate get a two-thirds majority to
convict trump in the coming weeks
let me ask you about another aspect of
what we heard there
uh from the president he mentioned not
only lying for uh purposes of power but
also
purposes of profit and that goes to the
role of the media which in fact was one
of the
points mentioned by uh by those box pops
that we heard with that one woman saying
i don't know
what media to believe joe biden's asking
americans to
hear him out and to listen to each other
but will they be able to do
that given the din of poisonous chatter
on polarized media from fox news to the
social media platforms
i'm afraid the polarization of the media
will even accelerate
the cocooning of people just in their
own
living in their own world will
accelerate and one thing that
contributes
to this is the banning from trump from
twitter and facebook
and youtube and instagram because that
leads to the
thing that that even twitter is seen as
partisan and and
other like parlor and other uh uh forums
are coming up
uh so that that not just the the tv
stations and the
and the printed media are polarized but
now the social media as well gets more
and more polarized and
allows people to stay in their own
bubble if if i could just
expand on that i do think though
americans and even president biden
recognizes that
the democracy is very fragile he said
that in his speech
and social media and the fact that
journalism is so fragmented in the
united states plays a role
unfortunately in this functionality and
i won't be surprised to see if there
is uh more regulation of big tech in
washington moving forward
i want to come to that as one of the
policy priorities of the next
administration but let me ask you about
one
other uh point uh suda when we look at
that both the inauguration ceremony and
the new administration
we see an absolutely astonishing degree
of diversity in fact if we take gender
into account this
is the most diverse cabinet in history
so clearly that will be read as a signal
of
hope and change and unity by the many
americans who are worried about
structural racism
but what about the others well you know
i think if joe biden
as he said in his speech works for
all americans and most likely this is
his
only term in office and he said that
he's going to go in it with
all his soul because he has really
nothing to lose this is probably his
last term in office
so he i think he will make it a point to
make sure that the american middle class
gets its strength back and um yes the
diversity in the cabinet is very
important very symbolic to what our
country stands for
but it's also the he picked experts it
really is a technocratic for example
national security team
so even though it's symbolic he also has
real professionals behind him when it
comes to foreign policy for example
in fact interestingly enough some of the
uh
most diverse faces are also the most
moderate
members of the cabinet structural racism
is just
one of the complex problems that
president biden has promised
to address with rapid action he takes
office in the midst of an
unprecedented crisis in the face of
mismanagement at federal level
the u.s has seen the most coveted deaths
of any country worldwide
and that has had deep repercussions on
the economy
here's a closer look at the new
president's tough priorities
fighting the coronavirus the u.s has
seen the most coveted 19 deaths of any
country worldwide
what will joe biden do differently he
plans to invest 160 billion dollars in
testing
vaccines and health personnel and impose
a mask mandate
rebuilding the u.s economy in light of
the devastating economic impact of the
pandemic
biden has announced a 1.9 trillion
dollar stimulus program
it includes massive investments in
businesses research
and infrastructure
increasing action on climate change
joe biden has vowed to promptly rejoin
the paris climate agreement
he also wants the u.s to be climate
neutral by 2050
overhauling trump's immigration policies
joe biden will overturn the travel ban
for citizens from several muslim
countries
he also wants to open a path to
citizenship for millions of migrants who
currently live in the u.s
without a residency permit
[Music]
with these measures biden intends to
quickly reverse the policies of his
predecessor
but could that jeopardize attempts at
reconciliation with trump supporters
matthew biden seems to be assuming that
pandemic recovery in both the health and
economic senses
is something that can unify and
really bring both sides together but
even mask wearing became a partisan
issue under donald trump so two
questions
uh will that change and does fine
need to bring in politicians from the
other side malta is reminding us in fact
the democrats do have at least a thin
majority in both houses of congress
i think that mask wearing will remain a
partisan issue
i'm not sure how much that will matter
in the long term because of the
availability of vaccines and so many
people
have had uh covet now in the united
states to be honest that
uh you know you're you're approaching a
point where
you know the mask might not matter as
much as it does in other countries
um i think that biden will need
cooperation
from the other side on a lot of these
threats he does have a majority for the
next two years
in two years they're going to be new
elections midterm elections as they're
called in the united states in the in
the house of representatives
and in the senate and there you could
see these majorities
slip so i think he does need to move
fast to get
you know what he can through now and to
not antagonize
uh the republicans maybe uh too much
that they're going to sort of
seek revenge on his agenda soda your
opening statement talked about policy
for the middle class
and in fact republicans who celebrated
their great love for the middle class
and uh also supported an enormous rise
in the national debt
are now pushing back on biden's recovery
program
saying it's much too generous how much
can he achieve with this wafer thin
majority he's got
particularly in terms of economic
recovery well i think he needs to
make it a point to republicans and he
has a good ally and janet yellen
as treasury secretary designate that
it's
necessary to um you know spend more to
get the united states out of this
economic crisis
and he does need republicans because he
wants to be able to legislate rather
than do everything
by executive order because you have
precedent like the
paris climate accord or the iran deal
where if the republicans do take the
majority in
2022 in the congress they can easily
reverse a lot of policies and i think
also for immigration reform it would be
very good to have republican support for
comprehensive immigration reform
malta with a view to the clock let me
ask you
to talk a little bit about the foreign
policy implications of biden's
priorities where do you seal real
opportunities for transatlantic
cooperation
i mean the revitalization of we're
calling the
the western world i mean if it's nato if
it's
europe and transatlantic relationship
that's a goal in itself that it's
revitalized and people are talking to
each other not just about each other
so i think strengthening of nato um
germany has tests to put some more money
in the defense budget
has to show willingness to to recognize
american demands as as as reasonable
and so i think um if if that is done
we've done a lot
but um what about climate because
climate was in fact one of the first
things joe biden did
right after he took office executive
order returning
very very important in european minds
and
but climate climate change as well as
the fight against climate change needs
time
if we talk about the next two years he
might have a conference in the united
states
even in this year international
conference about the climate i don't
know but
but the fight against climate change
need times and perseverance
his problem is he has to be fast with a
lot of things
uh reconstitution needs time but does he
has
he had just two years in two years if
the senate is occupied with impeachment
if they if he needs to reconcile first
before he goes
on so there is a sense of urgency in
doing things
but there are trends against working
against them matthew biden promised in
his inaugural address
i quote to repair relations with allies
in order to jointly address present and
future challenges
your opening statement casts doubt on
the
success of the repair effort as it were
which
present and future challenges do you
think are going to be especially thorny
for the transatlantic alliance
well to begin i would say north stream 2
which is the pipeline between
russia and germany that has been a thorn
in the side of the u.s and many other
german allies in europe for many years
germany has shown no signs
of being willing to let go of that
project that will
remain a problem malte mentioned the
investment in defense in germany that
will remain an issue but i think the
really big looming issue is china the
united states
sees china as a massive threat to
the western world and to the stability
of the world as a whole
europeans don't appear to agree with
that assessment
this is a consensus in the united states
between democrats and
republicans we just saw the eu led by
germany
sign an investment pact with china
against the objections of the incoming
biden administration
so i think that it's a little bit too
simple to say you know the atmospherics
are going
to improve because biden's a nice guy i
think it's going to remain very
difficult
soda i'm going to take us back to our
title for the last few seconds of the
program
we talked about the wrecking ball of
trumpism
has trumpism wrought irreversible damage
in transatlantic relations i mean it
definitely has caused a lot of mistrust
among europeans about america
but i do believe that joe biden has a
chance to show
europeans and others that america is
back in its traditional role
but we'll approach things differently
with more restraint and humility
thank you very much great closing words
for our show
on the new president joe biden thanks
all to all of you out there for tuning
in
see you soon
you